sup guys welcome back to some more for
honor videos in today's topic as shown
by the title it's going to talk about
how to rank up the highest now if you
guys don't know or if you don't remember
you have to get to level 20 for one of
your heroes and then you can get them to
reputation one now I have asked a player
of war honour who is very good and I
asked him in the comments on reddit and
he is a third prestige level 2 Berserker
now this was during the beta so
everything got reset but give him a
couple of days I'll probably be back at
it again but I did ask him in the
comments and he gave me some feedback on
what he did and I'm going to share that
all with you so I just want to say thank
you to him basically what he stated to
get the highest rank in for honor is a
few things one you want to make use of
the champion status one of the things I
noticed is that champion status will
give you more steel and more XP per game
than the normal player without it there
is a video by the Brody Bros so shout
out to them for how to get your free
10-day champion status instead of like
purchasing it I found out that if you
have twitch Prime if any of you people
have twitch prime you will get a tenday
champion status or for the people that
don't have twitch prime you can go over
to the ubisoft website and then select
your 30-day free trial and then that
will still count as you having twitch
Prime you'll get the 10-day and then if
you never really use to which again who
cares because you just got 10 days of
champion status for yourself another
thing you can do is just you know the
normal grinding out the game playing
over and over and over again that could
be boring that was an obvious answer
another one that I decide that I
actually came up with a couple couple
minutes ago before I started making this
was the contract orders if you go over
to the contract orders you'll notice
that most of them give you steel as an
extra reward but all of them like all of
them give you experience between 500 to
1000 and then 1500 experience points
depending on how hard it is for example
you could have complete 5 Dominion
matches or get like 15 takedowns in a
map or in a match
something like that and it will give you
experience points when you know what the
character you complete it with there's
just some simple things you can do to
rank up your character and get them
within like a couple days just have a
reputation the next video I'm going to
be coming out with tomorrow is going to
be stating now that we've got the the
leveling how do we get the gear because
if you're overpowered and if you have
overpowered gear but a really low level
doesn't really make a lot of sense
because then because that reputation one
that's that's when it starts dropping
blue type of gear and then at reputation
3 you start dropping purple gear but
I'll cover all that tomorrow and you
know tomorrow's video but just simple
stuff on how to rank up guys really
quick really simple I want to ask you
all a question if you did get this far
how are you guys enjoying the game is a
are you all having connection issues as
well or you just completely bypassing
that are you playing the story mode if
so you know just leave a comment if you
enjoyed the story mode please spoiler
free for all the people if you do
comment that just just a couple
questions I wanted to throw wrong there
but uh have a great day guys we'll see
you tomorrow